Well, guess I should stop looking for my smart gene.
>> Oh, Lauren, I wouldn't give up completely. I mean,
intelligence is complex. But, if you determine heritability first, and then
perform a genetic association study, you might have some luck
at determining multiple genetic factors that are associated with the trait.
>> I'm assuming this works with other complex
traits such as schizophrenia, anorexia, or even obsessive-compulsive disorder.
>> Absolutely, in theory.
Although we focused on the traits of risk for breast
cancer, height, and bipolar disorder, it should be understood that
the conclusions drawn and the methods used here would apply
to a whole host of other complex traits as well.
>> Well in that case, I think I
need to start my own genome-wide association study.
>> Oh, and what are you interested in searching for?
>> Why some people prefer beer. Why some people prefer wine.
>> Oh, I think you're definitely going to enjoy our next lesson then.
In the next lession, we're going to determine why and how differences
in our genomes can result in our various responses to particular drugs.